now let's go to Croydon where we're
joined by the Yuka candidate for Croydon
North winter McKenzie mr. McKenzie thank
you very much indeed for being with us
before we come on to you clips before
how you doing I'm good thanks what's
going on in Croydon of course it's very
much on a knife edge between
conservatives and labour well I've been
down here busy you know dealing with the
media and various aspects of the press
you know so I haven't really taken much
notice but what I can hear at them is
you keep you keep you keep and I
understand the you keep Fox as struck
yet again he's struck and there are
feathers everywhere I mean how did you
keep and that that word is with the
people the experts out there are the
voters and they've turned to you keep in
their droves we have a great leader mr.
Faraj and he this guy is almost
single-handedly but got the message
across to a great percentage of the
general public who are tired of being
deceived tired of being lied to
you know you have to look at Croydon and
what's going on in Croydon and use it as
an example for all the other boroughs
the schools the roads the big white
elephants everywhere well hang on mr.
Mackenzie I mean there's a problem with
all due respect you haven't won any
council seats in Croydon yet it doesn't
look as if you're going to man let's get
real let's listen to the public let's
listen to the voters the people who are
saying we have been disenfranchised and
if this broadcast was going out before
voting day I guarantee we'd clean up
we'd absolutely clean up because this
country and the people in it the voters
the real experts the people who work
seven days a week the people who are
tired of being lied to but the ones who
have been disenfranchised need a change
and the commentators like yourself and
those on all question time commentators
politicians they need to
listen and roll their sleeves up get out
of their offices and meet the people
hear what they have to say that's the
reality of it all